I feel so blessed more than anything and
just excited Becky G has a lot to
celebrate these days at just 20 years
old the pop star has scored her biggest
hit ever with my Otis the saucy Bop is
at eight hundred million YouTube views
and Counting
in real life Becky's got a very special
by your of her own her boyfriend of a
year-and-a-half professional soccer
player sebastian legette she opened up
to ET about their swoon worthy romance
right before taking the stage at her i
heart radio meet música show in LA
presented by JC Penney it seems like
you're soul mates I mean it kind of
feels like it - I'm not lying when I say
that I feel like there's there's
something really special in someone who
you know relationships do take effort I
mean he's an athlete I am you know
traveling and touring all the time we're
both super busy but when you don't even
have to think twice um you don't have to
doubt your relationship with someone and
you can just be who you are and kind of
be inspired by that person to be better
that is something like really beautiful
and I have never really experienced that
before the holidays are coming up could
there be an engagement oh my goodness
what would you say about him I wouldn't
I wouldn't happen it would have happened
this year no but if it was oh yes I
would say yes of course but now I guess
that day at a time he's the one yes
[Music]
you
[Music]